Це не просто - їздити дорогами Молдови.
Кожна поїздка - наче виклик у цій до болю бідній країні, розповідає Маріана Туркан.
І вона знає, про що говорить. Адже вона їздить усією країною із кампанією "Я обираю Молдову"
та переконує молодь не виїжджати за кордон. Масштаби еміграції - драматичні.
Немає більше робочих рук. Мої батьки, що живуть в селі, плачуть. Ціле село виїхало.
Мій батько каже: раніше, коли прокидався, вітався із сусідами праворуч, ліворуч, з усіх боків.
Нині можна з кимось привітатися, може, раз на тиждень.
Сьогодні Маріана відвідує село Дороцкая. Багато домівок тут стоять порожні.
Їхні мешканці виїхали на заробітки за кордон.
Дітей залишили у бабусь і дідусів, адже брати їх із собою - надто дорого.
У сільській школі Маріана запитує дітей:
Чиї батьки за кордоном?
Майже усі.
Потім жінка грає з дітьми у гру.
Один школяр каже слово.
Міграція.
Інші відповідають, що їм при цьому спадає на думку:
Сум.
Відчуження.
Ностальгія.
Одним із відповідальних за невтішну ситуацію в країні
вважається член парламенту Вадим Пістрінчук.
Він багато років був радником прем'єр-міністра Влада Філата, засудженого за корупцію.
Тепер чоловік в опозиції. В еміграції він вбачає й позитивні сторони.
Це люди, які присилають додому багато грошей.
Деякі навіть привозять сюди бізнес.
А коли вони приїжджають в гості додому, то демонструють гарну європейську моду.
Це все безвідповідальні балачки, вважає Траян Ківріга.
Чоловік - співзасновник двох IT-фірм у молдовській столиці - "Теквілл" та "Ай хаб" (Tekwill und "I Hub").
Після навчання у Німеччині він міг би знайти за кордоном високооплачувану роботу в айті-галузі.
Але чоловік хотів щось змінити на батьківщині.
Нині він допомагає молодим молдаванам засновувати старт-апи,
розбудовувати мережі та налагоджувати контакти з клієнтами, зокрема, за кордоном.
Молоді підприємці, які працюють тут, - це надія нашої країни.
Ми хочемо, щоб вони ділилися знаннями.
І ми сподіваємося, що багато молодих людей насміляться щось розбудовувати в країні.
І це конче необхідно, розповідає Траян та веде нас на цей ринок.
Тут він зустрічає найбідніших співгромадян, які вже втратили надію на роботу, безпеку чи добробут.
Багато хто розуміє, що за останні 30 років кожен другий залишив країну у пошуках роботи.
Надії на краще життя в них більше не залишилося.
Те, що ми бачимо на вулицях сьогодні, віддзеркалює драму нашого народу.
Ми всі переживаємо це в республіці Молдова.
Немає волі до змін, це трагедія.
Єдине рішення - якщо суспільство нарешті прокинеться та жорсткіше виступить проти корупції.
Я ще молодий, і це - моя перевага, я оптимістичніший.
Я вважаю, що з часом ми зможемо змінити ситуацію.
Із цим урядом? Вважаєте, у молоді є шанс щось змінити? У них немає жодних шансів!
Траян хоче все одно спробувати. І він сподівається, що інші також повернуться на батьківщину.
Тоді у Молдови був би шанс на краще життя.